[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce tweet spécial journal
internationale des droits de la femme
puisque nous sommes le 8 mars bienvenue
Mustapha bah oui vous êtes le président
de pharmacie de voyant les fondateurs de
pharmacie citoyens on va dire un mot
rapidement pharmaceutoyen la citoyenneté
les femmes alors comment dire un mot
d'abord merci Patrice pour cette idée de
réunir
les femmes vous allez voir des destins
absolument extraordinaire je trouve
aussi et donc merci pour cette
initiative et cette invitation pharmacie
citoyen créée en 2007 on pourrait dire
pharmacie citoyen pharmacitoyenne
simplement pour le titre je l'ai trouvé
parce que je suis pharmacien et citoyens
soyez des citoyens voilà donc en fait
l'idée de pharmacie citoyen c'est de
travailler sur les quartiers dit
sensibles avec plusieurs appellations
différentes en fonction des gouvernants
mais l'idée c'est de voilà promouvoir la
citoyenneté l'expliquer même aller au
contact des jeunes pour
vulgariser ce mot dont tout le monde
parle et finalement souvent la
définition est un peu compliquée donc
avec des idées simples et donc quand on
parle de PHARMAC citoyen ce sont des
sorties avec des enfants qui sont des
enfants CM2 et on fait donc le programme
d'histoire on va dire illustré par des
visites mémorielles ou des sites qui
sont des sites on va dire à caractère et
à valeur symbolique importantes alors la
citoyenneté c'est une notion qu'on
aborde souvent et chaque presque chaque
année puisque il y a eu
covid oblige des interruptions mais
c'est la deuxième année que Pharma
citoyen
se propose de célébrer cette journée en
tous les cas en parler de parler de ce
qui se passe le 8 mars de parler des
femmes alors on va vous présenter nos
invités dans quelques instants mais tout
de suite les infos du jour
une plante d'anticorps 78 visant Sidi
LMR l'association anticorruption
reproche à l'ancien maire par intérim de
Mantes-la-Jolie un conflit d'intérêt
dans le prolongement d'une convention
d'occupation d'un local municipal à
titre gratuit d'une association l'effet
alors que l'échéance n'était pas encore
arrivé et que Sidi et les meurt et le
directeur général de cette association
un second document concerne le bail
professionnel au bénéfice d'une
entreprise dirigée par son frère les
plaintes n'ont pour le moment pas donné
lieu à l'ouverture d'une procédure
judiciaire un coup de projecteur sur
leur carrière à l'occasion de la Journée
internationale des droits des femmes
plusieurs personnalités masculines du
monde de la technologie donne le temps
d'une journée de leur compte à une femme
certains eviloy y participent la raison
les femmes sont cinq fois moins
nombreuses dans ce secteur et moins
visible sur la plateforme que leurs
homologues masculins c'est une maladie
qui touche une femme sur dix
l'endométriose elle est devenue sujet
d'une stratégie nationale en janvier
2022 avec la création par l'Agence
régionale de santé Île-de-France de 4
filières dans les Yvelines à les
pilotées par les centres hospitaliers de
Versailles et de Poissy Saint-Germain la
filière se nomme voyelle et a été
officiellement lancée hier mardi 7 mars
pierre voyelle couvre le 78 et le 95
Ouest
et donc a pour mission de permettre à
toutes les femmes qui présentent de
l'endométriose d'avoir un diagnostic
précoce et une prise en charge adaptée
graduée en fonction de sa situation à
partir du médecin généraliste de la
sage-femme libérale du gynécologue de
ville mais aussi d'autres professionnels
qui vont pouvoir et les aider les
soulager que peuvent être déclinés des
ostéopathes etc la consultation
gynécologique peut permettre d'évoquer
le diagnostic c'est ce qui a été
notifié par la Haute Autorité de Santé
en 2017 dans les recommandations qui
fallait avoir un interrogatoire à ces
standardisés et aussi dans la mesure du
possible un examen gynécologique un
examen pelvien qui est qui permet de
détecter des signes la mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites continue
ce mercredi 8 mars notamment les
transports étaient à nouveau perturbés
une troisième journée de grève d'affilée
ce profil jeudi 9 mars et l'intersydical
annonçait deux nouvelles journées le
samedi 11 mars et le 14 ou le 15 mars
[Musique]
alors on a cinq invités
trois premières Brigitte chalonard
bonjour
alors vous êtes vous êtes aussi impliqué
dans la pharmacie citoyen oui absolument
Mustapha a eu la gentillesse de
m'inviter à faire partie de son
association donc en tant que bénévole de
manière on va dire assez assez légère
mais surtout j'ai ma fille la cadette
qui bénéficie du programme de CM2 avec
les sorties qui revient enchantés
épanouie de toutes ces découvertes donc
voilà je me remercierai jamais assez
Mustapha pour pour ces expériences
inoubliable
les les filles soient impliquées dans ce
genre de d'initiatives absolument on est
essentiellement sur des clubs de foot
avec une grande partie de de garçons et
sur trappes c'est grâce à
l'intermédiaire de l'OMS avec des un
groupe essentiellement constitué de
filles
fondatrice de c'est le monde de
l'entreprise
qui est absolument exceptionnel vous
avez une entreprise qui s'appelle IMA
oil c'est ça
alors il met vous avez enfin hier vous
avez aimé vous avez IMA qui veut dire
maman berbère
comment vous avez parce que vous avez
mêlé aussi votre enfant vos racines et
le monde de l'entreprise absolument
vous avez la culture en fait c'est ce
qui relie tout le monde parce que on a
des parcours différents on a des vécus
différents et donc la culture c'est ce
qui nous permet d'échanger c'est ce qui
permet le lien et
c'est quelque chose qui fait d'air et
donc c'est vrai que c'est pour moi
quelque chose qui me fait vibrer puisque
mon travail me permet justement de
mettre en lien les uns avec les autres
et de pouvoir comprendre que chaque vie
est unique et que du coup le plus beau
dans cette vie c'est de pouvoir partager
sa vie avec les autres et de pouvoir il
y a autant de vérités que d'êtres
humains et donc de pouvoir échanger et
de pouvoir se rencontrer voilà la
rencontre
et le monde de la citoyenneté le monde
de la culture le monde de l'entreprise
tout à l'heure on aura deux autres
invités qui sont qui s'épanouissent dans
un monde peut-être on parle un peu moins
des femmes c'est le monde du foot alors
on en parle de plus en plus est-ce que
c'est pour les bonnes raisons on en
reparlera tout à l'heure alors justement
vous avez rencontré ou des difficultés
ou est-ce contraire ça vous a facilité
de faciliter votre évolution d'être des
femmes
faciliter
pour ma part facilité je sais pas en
tout cas j'ai pas spécialement rencontré
des difficultés en tant qu'entrepreneuse
c'est pour moi ça a été simplement un
parcours entrepreneurial qui est fait de
d'embûches de voilà de plein de choses
mais je pense que n'importe quel
entrepreneur qu'on soit femme ou homme
je pense qu'on a tous rencontré le même
problématiques en tout cas moi je vois
pas ça comme un comme des obstacles
plutôt des challenges à relever et voilà
donc je les relève et j'avance voilà
tout simplement donc ça reste un défi en
plus ou c'est un défi uniquement
entrepreneurial
entrepreneurial tout simplement parce
que voilà quand on a
exactement on aurait eu les mêmes
problèmes voilà donc je dirais pas j'ai
pas vraiment rencontré des problèmes
voilà ce point ce point de vue au
contraire donc raconte-nous un peu quand
même votre vie vous êtes né à Tiznit
c'est ça
quand même en France j'avais 6 ans
et
donc moi j'ai je suis grandi dans un
environnement familial ou les femmes
avaient quand même de l'importance qui
voilà c'était tout tourné autour de la
femme donc moi j'ai pas vraiment vécu la
femme inférieure ou au contraire c'est
la femme a beaucoup de valeur dans la
famille et c'est elle qui décide en fait
si ça se dit pas ou
je sais pas si on n'a pas besoin de le
dire en fait c'est
comme ça c'est le respect entre
et surtout moi j'ai été élevé dans une
culture où on n'a pas fait où mes
parents n'ont jamais fait de différence
entre moi et mes frères on nous a élevé
de la même manière on nous a jamais dit
vous si vous êtes pas capable de faire
ça moi je viens d'une famille enfin mon
père est entrepreneur il nous a toujours
élevé danse qu'on soit indépendant et et
me faire comprendre qu'il y a pas de
barrière que tout est il faisable et que
voilà quoi que tu sois j'ai jamais eu
ressenti en fait ces différences entre
moi et mon frère par exemple on nous a
élevé de la même manière il nous a fait
travailler de la même manière
il m'a pas fait plus de cadeaux comme
mon frère
donc
il vous a pas couvé parce que vous étiez
et quand vous arrivez en France donc
vous avez 6 ans
là ça se passe comment c'est parce que
vous dites voilà les femmes ont une
grande importance
là où vous êtes né au Maroc est-ce que
c'est la même chose quand on arrive dans
un pays il faut découvrir c'est un peu
plus différents quand on a j'avais six
sept ans
[Musique]
la femme dans l'entreprise ou dans
l'entrepreneuriat et vous c'est quelque
chose que vous évacuez en tant que femme
mais par contre il y a cette notion
d'étrangère ou de minorites parce que
c'est une minorité oui mais on
fait on fait semblant de ne pas le voir
on a enfin c'est pas quelque chose qui
nous enfin c'est très ça reste quand
même très minoritaire voilà et pourtant
parce qu'on parle des femmes mais le mot
de maman revient souvent puisque on a
une maman accompagnatrice on est maman
qui vient avec sa fille à pharmacie
citoyen au passage très modestement
reviendra sur le parcours de Béatrice
mais très modestement a fait un travail
exceptionnel autour des mamans justement
mais l'entreprise c'est maman
l'huile l'huile de maman qui est des
femmes autour de ma famille qui m'ont
inspiré et notamment ma grand-mère que
j'ai vu enfin fabriquer des huiles
d'argan des mêmes etc
c'est pour ça que je disais qu'il y
avait aussi une tradition parce que vous
avez été élevé là ou alors mais j'ai lu
quand même une phrase vous disiez je me
sens comme une guerrière je sens moi le
le la force des femmes berbères en fait
ouais c'est vrai qu'on alors je sais pas
si c'est propre au fait qu'on ait des
Berbères ou quoi mais moi j'ai en moi
ici enfin cette force guerrière
effectivement qui a rien qui m'arrête
quand je vois c'est pour ça que je vous
dis que je vois rien comme obstacle en
fait je quand je vois un problème je
pivote mon projet quand je vois quelque
chose qui va pas bah je tourne mon
projet je le pivote et je repars où je
recule pour voilà j'essaie toujours de
faire en sorte de il y a rien qui puisse
me dire voilà exactement donc
exactement survivant alors vous avez
c'est impossible je me dis un problème
on va le solutionner et puis on va
repartir
donc vous avez toujours eu l'idée de
devenir chef d'entreprise de fonder
votre oui pour moi c'était
pas une finalité mais mais je voyais ça
comme quelque chose
des problèmes mais c'est quand même
nettement plus
ça nous tracasse plus les hommes se
posent moins de questions je pense que
nous ils ont leur carrière ils trassent
nous on a toujours cette cette volonté
de de cumuler correctement notre
carrière sans pénaliser notre famille et
je pense que c'est une sorte de
culpabilité
ça vous êtes d'accord je suis d'accord
c'est juste que effectivement moi je me
pose pas le problème entre mes femmes je
trouve que voilà qu'elle existence d'un
homme et une femme c'est tout à fait
naturel et que vont être toujours été un
combat quel est le rôle de l'homme quel
est le rôle de la femme c'est une
complémentarité en fait le problème
homme-femme pour moi se pose pas après
du tout pas du tout non au contraire moi
je pense que vous avez des
responsabilités
bien au contraire c'est à dire que voilà
c'est cette cette manière d'aborder les
choses peut-être cette vision différente
la femme donne la vie donc elle voit les
choses différemment je pense qu'on est
structuré différemment un homme et une
femme on voit pas les choses la même
manière mais ça reste complémentaire
après il faut pas je pense que le
problème de l'égalité homme-femme
s'oppose sur le plan administratif mais
c'est vrai qu'on a tendance à dévier ce
problème là en disant l'égalité entre
mes femmes enfin moi personnellement je
ne réclame pas l'égalité je ne suis pas
légale de l'homme on est complémentaire
on a chacun sa spécificité nous on donne
la vie donc voilà c'est différent et ce
sont deux choses qui je ne suis pas
légale vous voulez dire voilà on n'est
pas fait tout à fait pareil c'est ça
vous parlez pas évidemment du droit et
vous parler de l'économie va si ça par
contre économiquement parlant oui on est
égaux à travailler égal salaire égal
voilà conditions égales en même temps on
a des rôles différents c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui voilà il y a le problème de
la famille qui se pose les enfants
notamment nous on donne la vie et c'est
vrai qu'on a des préoccupations qui ne
sont peut-être pas celles de l'homme qui
aujourd'hui reste dans le schéma
archaïque ramené de l'argent ramener
protéger et c'est vrai que du coup les
choses je veux dire une femme va comment
dire va être beaucoup plus souple sur sa
carrière parce que derrière il y a ses
enfants elle a une vision différente de
de la chose mais voilà moi en tant que
femme tout à fait c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui je pense que le fait de
parler de la différence homme femme fait
plus de dégâts que de bien parce que on
est fait pour se rencontrer on est fait
pour être ensemble et en effet pour
donner la vie ensemble la vie ne peut
pas se donner une femme toute seule un
homme tout seul la vie elle est bien
faite la nature est très bien faite donc
il faut la laisser faire son travail
féministes qui fait que qui fait que
parfois on sent un peu de guerre qui se
entre les sacs parce que parce que c'est
vrai que le il y a détermination
masculine pendant des siècles des
siècles et que c'est normal qu'il y ait
un contrepoids et voilà mais parfois ça
va jusqu'à la jusqu'à faire une une
hostilité entre le sexe vous vous dites
c'est pas c'est pas le France jusqu'en
1944 la femme pouvait pas voter donc
c'est vrai que c'est une justice c'est
oui c'est très tard c'est une vraie
injustice mais qui se corrige au fil du
temps mais en même temps après ça
n'engage que moi on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui aussi on évolue vers des
temps où on demande tellement de choses
à la femme qu'un moment donné s'en est
trop c'est-à-dire il faut être maman il
faut être compétentes il faut travailler
il faut dire parfois il y a des femmes
qui explosent au vol parce que voilà on
a tellement envie d'être légal
si on arrive à trouver la vie est un
équilibre le la nature est un équilibre
donc même dans les rapports hommes et
femmes il faut trouver cet équilibre
tant sur le plan personnel que sur le
plan professionnel et pourtant Patrice
le rappelait il y a une domination
importante des hommes pendant très
longtemps aujourd'hui on va vers un
équilibre on parle de la France au
passage mais la journée internationale
des droits des femmes va chercher la
femme dans le monde entier la place de
la femme dans le monde qui n'est pas
celle de la femme en France ou dans
d'autres pays parce qu'il y a quand même
des débats qui nous traversent comme par
exemple le féminisme qui est un
mouvement important et qui a un rôle
important mais de la même façon on voit
émerger le masculinisme c'est-à-dire
qu'en gros les féministes d'un côté les
masculines de l'autre et on voit bien
qu'il y a quand même un débat voire des
hostilités
ce sont des gens qui c'est
hors du temps mais qui existe c'est ça
que je veux dire et ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il y a quand même ce débat qui
est sur la place publique surtout aux
États-Unis parce que ça vient souvent de
ça vient souvent de là-bas de tout ce
qui est un peu outrancier mais le
masculinisme c'est le masculin qui se
revendit comme étant dominant et le
revendique comme tel heureusement un peu
moins j'en reviens quand même parce que
pour justement c'est à la fois pour
raconter un peu votre histoire et puis
voir comment ce parcours se fait
quand vous créez votre votre entreprise
je crois que avec 8000 euros c'est ça
un capital de 8000 euros alors j'ai fait
appel à initiative en plus de 8000 euros
j'ai quand même eu un prêt d'honneur par
initiative 95 qui est à 0 % et puis ma
banque m'a complété derrière
elle est formidable elle est géniale
elle est géniale
on a compris
[Applaudissements]
et alors
ouais non je vois pas non j'ai défendu
mon projet j'ai eu un super jury qui a
cru en mon projet et qui a accepté mon
prêt d'honneur et tout de suite après au
contraire c'est quand je dis que sinon
qui nous mettons des barrières du fait
qu'on est très sécurité etc je me
rappelle de ma banque qui m'avait dit
mais allez-y j'avais vraiment fait je
n'arrivais pas à voir en fait à me voir
dans deux ans quand vous savez quand on
vous demande de préparer des des
business plan et qu'on vous dit
qu'est-ce que comment vous allez
qu'est-ce que vous allez devenir dans
trois ans bah je sais pas en fait je
sais pas
je sais même pas demain
et puis voilà on voyait mon projet que
quelque chose d'extraordinaire il m'a
manqué on vous suit allez-y prenez plus
on vous suit je dis non moi j'ai si je
rembourse pas genre et si j'arrive pas à
rembourser je sais pas
vous dire que c'est nous qui nous
mettons des obstacles maintenant avec
l'expérience évidemment j'aurais pris
plus mais mais non non je dis au passage
elles nous font la gentillesse d'être là
j'en profite quand même pour faire un
peu de promotion puisque votre marque
est en pharmacie
parce que vous avez commencé le
développement de développement
le premier objectif moi alors après 20
ans des expertise en milieu informatique
je t'ai responsable des achats et je
faisais rentrer des laboratoires je
signais des marchés etc et j'ai fait un
constat alarmant qui m'a beaucoup
touchée c'est que quand on voit des des
produits venant de l'Afrique du Maroc
entre autres comme je parle de l'huile
d'argan mais je peux aussi parler de la
karité et d'autres produits africains
j'ai senti comme enfin on a au Maroc le
monopole mondial de l'Argan il ne pousse
nulle part ailleurs dans le monde cause
une seule région et la région justement
où je suis né donc c'est vraiment un
véritable produit rare c'est un trésor
ce produit et pourtant on le voit dans
des petits flacons de bas de bas de
gamme on me le présente avec des tarifs
très très compétitifs très bas de prix
et je me suis demandé pourquoi et les
gens n'ont réclamé pas parce que voilà
en se disait pas forcément c'est pas
qualitatif
et donc à force de me questionner je me
suis rendue compte que les grands
industriels
avaient fait perdre la dorure de cette
fameuse huile d'argan que ma grand-mère
fabriquée d'elle-même donc en faisant un
petit peu mon étude du marché je me suis
rendu compte qu'elles allaient acheter
des des
qualités
qu'ils transformés et en faisant Seb on
retirer tous ces bienfaits et donc ils
allaient tous favoriser la pardon ils
utilisent des procédés de vaporisation
qui vont aller donner plus de quantité
qu'à la qualité et j'évolue voilà lui
rembourse
et vous avez créé des coopératives
d'ailleurs de femmes au Maroc
j'ai été travailler j'ai été chercher
des coopératives dans le village de ma
grand-mère et j'ai décidé de travailler
avec ces femmes justement pour les aider
il y a parce qu'il y a quand même un
impact social derrière qui que je mets
au coeur du processus de fabrication de
notre marque donc ce sont des femmes
parce qu'on peut aussi se poser des
questions pourquoi l'huile d'argan est
connue on en trouve partout dans le
monde aux États-Unis au Japon etc et
pourtant on a toujours ces femmes dans
des villages marocains qui sont un
alphabète qui ont vivent toujours pas et
que elle-même et elle-même elles
prennent pas ça comme quelque chose
comme un travail et que ils prennent ça
comme étant à une euh
voilà c'est ça une occupation histoire
de les faire sortir de chez elle et
cetera donc j'ai été un petit peu déjà
des formé leur expliquer que que lui il
avait de la valeur et qu'il fallait
aujourd'hui
c'est ça exactement c'est du
gagnant-gagnant bravo
c'est de la création de valeur et la
création de valeur effectivement
aujourd'hui ce qui marche très bien quoi
ça se développe on est encore là donc
tout va bien donc dans le secteur ça va
probablement se développer
là je rentre je suis rentré du Sud on a
été on est implanté dans la plus grande
grosse pharmacie d'Europe qui est à Cap
3000 qui nous suivent depuis le début
d'ailleurs et donc on anime on est sur
Monaco aussi on est vraiment un peu
parti dans toutes les régions françaises
dont les voilà donc on est ravi et
probablement sur le territoire bientôt
on va faire connaissance de votre marque
vous la culture vous l'avez rencontrer
comment alors moi j'ai un un peu
atypique
j'ai fait du théâtre quand j'étais jeune
et puis voilà il fallait faire des
études donc j'ai fait des études
scientifiques
oui tout à fait donc en biologie donc
j'ai travaillé dans la recherche
fondamentale pendant plus de 10 ans
et puis mon amour pour pour la culture
il a été beaucoup plus fort donc grâce à
une rencontre fortuite voilà qui s'est
faite comme ça la vie est un fait de
rencontre mais il y a pas de hasard je
pense qu'il y a pas de hasard il y a que
des rendez-vous et donc j'ai évolué dans
ce domaine là donc je suis revenue un
petit peu au domaine que j'aimais
beaucoup parce que je voulais être
chanteuse lyrique quand j'étais petite
mais c'est un rêve que je n'ai pas
réalisé et donc voilà et puis de fil en
aiguille ça s'est fait comme ça et du
coup mon métier en fait n'est pas juste
un métier de d'organisation d'événements
pas du tout je pars du principe que mon
métier est un métier de rencontre et en
fait la culture n'est qu'un moyen
il faut complètement il faut il faut
aussi amener les les gens c'est pas
facile
donc
toutes les festivals que vous organisez
tout ça mais
voilà il a fait amener les gens c'est
pas c'est pas évident si je prends par
exemple le festival de la bande dessinée
est un exemple très concret puisque au
départ c'était un festival de dédicace
et puis enfin je me suis rendu compte
que la BD est un outil redoutable
puisqu'il touche toutes les générations
et donc à travers ces outils en fait on
a organisé on a collecté des fonds que
ce soit au sein du privé ou des
institutions et avec cet outil on va
aller ce que j'appelle j'aime beaucoup
ce mot semer parce que semer s'est
récolté et donc on va aller vers des
gens qui sont très éloignés de la
culture notamment les prisonniers les
enfants malades les seniors enfin les
EHPAD et donc on a fait énormément de
projets d'ordre pédagogiques à viser
social et la culture doit être un biais
justement pour amener tout le monde à se
rencontrer et d'intégration voilà donc
au passage
donc il y a pas de hasard et des
rendez-vous on a eu rendez-vous ensemble
puisque merci en tous les cas c'est
réciproque mais c'est surtout les
invitations
au théâtre à la culture proposé à les
enfants proposaient à nos enfants
et donc j'en profite publiquement pour
vous remercier pour cette initiative
parce que vous avez des initiative dans
d'autres domaines mais également les
enfants de ces fameuses cités dans ton
parle des quartiers dont on parle en
tout cas devant pharmacie citoyen
s'occupe et donc on a eu le droit à des
places de théâtre gratuites pour les
enfants
absolument grâce à elle et grâce à un
peu le combat
parce que vous avez dit vous avez écrit
aussi comment ça s'est passé ça en fait
le partenariat avec le festival de but
et puis la ville de Buc parce que quand
je suis arrivée je me suis rendu compte
que c'est une ville qui a une histoire
très très riche et puis moi le
patrimoine ça a toujours été quelque
chose qui m'a dit l'histoire en fait
parce que l'histoire c'est ce qui nous
construit c'est ce qui nous c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui fait voilà c'est ce qui
nous relie et c'est ce qui fait ce qu'on
nous sommes aujourd'hui et c'est tout un
parcours tout un process
et donc en fait parce que au fond on
n'est pas libre de tout c'est notre
histoire qui fait qu'on devient ce qu'on
est et du coup je me suis rendu compte
qu'un but qui avait une histoire
extrêmement riche mais qui n'était pas
très connue on a un service des archives
qui est extrêmement bien tenu c'est un
trésor donc voilà donc j'ai commencé à
fouiller et puis on est parti sur la
l'écriture de l'histoire aéronautique de
la ville de Buc pour faire connaître
l'histoire c'est une manière aussi de
faire travailler les enfants
qui s'approprient leur territoire et
puis de ce bouquin à découler d'autres
bouquins on a raconté l'histoire parce
que le patrimoine pour moi c'est pas que
le patrimoine immatériel mais c'est
aussi les êtres humains donc on a écrit
un bouquin sur les les comment dire les
poilus les 14-18 on a raconté l'histoire
de Buc sous une forme BD enfin on a
écrit plusieurs ouvrages dans ce sens
pour justement raconter l'histoire et
faire en sorte que les gens puissent
avoir cette connexion avec leur ville et
avec leur ville et avec le monde
bien comme on vous le dites que le temps
mieux d'autant bien je pense que ça sort
bon c'est ma première présentation de
mission d'autant mieux que il y a même
un projet qui pourrait naître entre nous
entre pharmacie citoyen puisque la BD
vous maîtrisez et la vulgarisation de la
citoyenneté pourrait y passer par ce
biais également donc un projet pourrait
naître de parler de la citoyenneté très
simplement par le biais de la BD aux
enfants tout à fait pourquoi parce que
en fait nous on s'est rendu compte enfin
en tout cas les ateliers sont la manière
dont on les mène
en fait vous réunissez des gens qui sont
très différents donc ce qui est ce qui
va les relier c'est la BD mais d'abord
trouver la bonne personne qui va matcher
avec le public visé en fonction du
public qu'on va viser on va pas aborder
la question de la même manière quand on
a affaire à des seniors ou à des
prisonniers qui vous disent moi la BD
que vous voulez que je fasse enfin je
veux dire je je suis dans dans une
situation difficile je te souvenais me
raconter avec votre BD mais l'idée c'est
de dire nous on part sur un projet mais
il y a aucune performance artistique
c'est pas ce qu'on recherche et l'idée
c'est d'amener les gens autour d'un
projet et bien celui qui ne s'est pas
dessiner d'abord c'est raconter c'est en
fait mettre ses émotions donner une
forme aux émotions et puis je ne sais
pas dessiner parce que c'est toujours la
première chose qu'on nous dit et ben il
faut savoir raconter on peut raconter
quelque chose on peut imaginer un
scénario on peut colorier et petit à
petit en fait il y a quelque chose qui
n'est entre ces gens là et qui fait
qu'un projet va naître
qui est le leur et dont ils vont prendre
la responsabilité et puis l'envie de le
mener à bout et petit à petit on se rend
compte que les gens en fait réalisent
qu'ils ont beaucoup de ressources c'est
parce que ils sont dans un moment ce que
j'appelle la parenthèse tant espace qui
fait qu'on se relâche on est bien et
puis on donne ce qu'on a de plus
précieux et c'est là où on se rend
compte en fait c'est notre but c'est de
se rendre compte à quel point chaque
être humain a des ressources et qu'on
est tous unique et on le sera jusqu'à la
fin des temps et donc cette forme unique
fait que on est un maillon de la chaîne
voilà et qu'on est important dans la
société
[Rires]
Béatrice qui a également un discours
donc pareil qu'un parcours très
intéressant puisqu'on est dans la
diversité des parcours plutôt que de
parler théorie sur cette journée on est
vraiment sur le parcours et c'est très
intéressant comme ça et donc Béatrice
au-delà de son parcours professionnel et
personnel il y a ce parcours attrape
parcours personnel donc j'ai grandi à
Clermont-Ferrand jusqu'à l'âge de 21 ans
et puis après un séjour à l'étranger
pendant pendant mes études je suis
arrivée sur sur l'agglomération pour
pour travailler donc j'ai travaillé une
dizaine d'années dans l'automobile dans
l'industrie automobile en tant que
assistante commerciale international et
acheteuse international et puis j'ai eu
envie de d'entrepreneuriat donc voilà
donc ça fait une dizaine d'années que je
suis formatrice à mon compte en français
langue étrangère en anglais en allemand
donc j'accompagne essentiellement des
adultes qui souhaitent évoluer
professionnellement donc que ce soit
pour en français langue étrangère ça
peut être pour maîtriser maîtriser mieux
l'écrit et puis permettre d'atteindre
des postes auxquels ils auraient pas pu
prétendre voilà et puis de même pour
l'anglais l'allemand permettre d'avoir
des connaissances suffisantes pour
atteindre un poste maîtriser des
situations voilà et alors en plus comme
disait Mustapha une application
contribution la société si je peux dire
dans le domaine associatif et dans le
domaine dont vous impliquez dans la
citoyenneté du coup on peut pas dire ça
j'attache beaucoup d'importance à
l'aspect citoyen social j'ai participé
j'ai été présidente du comité de
quartier pendant des années j'ai attrape
oui oui donc j'habite trappes depuis
2003 ça fait ça fait 20 ans maintenant
donc pour moi c'est c'est vraiment un
vrai choix je tiens à le dire c'est
c'est un choix c'est pas j'ai pas
atterri là par hasard ça fait partie de
des valeurs que je tiens que que je
voulais pour mes enfants aussi grandir
dans dans une ville multiculturelle avec
une ouverture d'esprit et voilà donc ça
c'est important et puis participer voilà
à la vie à la vie de la ville la vie la
vie de citoyenne les associations donc
quand j'ai rencontré Mustapha et Pharma
citoyens le projet m'a parlé d'accord il
travaille qui est fait auprès de maman
essentiellement ce qu'on a beaucoup de
filles qui viennent de Trappes grâce au
travail de Béatrice et des mamans qui
l'entourent
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
mais c'est vrai que dans les quartiers
vous parliez tout à l'heure le quartier
politique de la ville ou quartier
la place des femmes des mères des filles
elle est essentielle elle est souvent
peu valorisée
et donc les contacts informels sont
vraiment
ultra important pour permettre aux
femmes de valoriser sans il n'y a pas
besoin d'être connu c'est juste
valoriser l'importance de chacune via
des contacts que ce soit dans les
centres sociaux que ce soit au marché
voilà il y a beaucoup de contacts
informels entre femmes et ça fait partie
de la vie pour pour nous à notre niveau
et quand on se bat comme vous
qu'on prend de son temps pour les autres
est-ce qu'il y a il y a on ressent
parfois des satisfactions fortes après
toutes les questions d'équilibre
un peu désespoir nous aussi ou non il y
a c'est plus des satisfactions c'est
plus positif
parfois il y a des il y a des moments où
c'est un petit peu frustrant de se dire
bah voilà on a passé du temps sur
certaines choses on aurait voulu que ça
se passe différemment mais ça c'est
c'est le lot de la vie donc c'est ça
fait partie voilà on est quand on donne
du temps on est on sait aussi comprendre
des risques sur sur le temps qu'on
consacre et c'est jamais perdu pour
c'est jamais totalement perdu
et vous diriez quoi parce qu'on a
entendu tout à l'heure ces notions de
pivot toutes ces notions où on passe à
côté d'un problème pour les pour
l'éviter finalement et continuer à
avancer pareil en tant que femme est-ce
que vous avez rencontré des difficultés
pour l'entrepreneuriat ou au contraire
pour l'entrepreneuriat pas directement
je rejoins effectivement l'idée de du
fait que il faut pas qu'on se mette
nous-mêmes les barrières parce qu'en
fait les barrières on peut toujours les
contourner ou les ou les sauter à
condition d'avoir vraiment une une
volonté forte
il y a souvent des solutions voilà on
peut pas dire toujours mais il y a
souvent des solutions qu'on soit homme
qu'on soit femme c'est pas c'est pas ce
qui ce qui va
malheureusement parce qu'on pourrait
avoir un dernier on la posera
il va falloir qu'on accueille deux
autres invités qui sont Latifa
qui travaille alors on disait dans le
monde du sport donc bah merci merci
infiniment à toutes les trois
bah continuez parce que ce que vous
faites absolument formidable on va on va
on va peut-être
évoquer un souvenir qui se passe en 2016
vous parliez des voyages de Fabrice
citoyens et vous allez ce jour-là près
de Bordeaux
au musée de la sécurité sociale je crois
non absolument musée de la sécurité
sociale en un mot
sportif et en même temps vous allez voir
c'est aussi le monde de la générosité et
de la solidarité je vous remercie encore
on regarde ce sujet et puis on a on
accueille nos deux prochaines invités
si la plupart des enfants profitent
encore de leur lit en vacances c'est 23
jeunes du club de foot de l'Étoile
Sportive de Trappes eux sont bien
matinaux mardi 26 avril il s'apprête à
embarquer pour 6 heures de bus
destination le musée national de la
sécurité sociale le rapport entre la
sécu et le football
il y a un mot simple
ça s'appelle le collectif 6 heures du
matin départ pour Lormont à côté de
Bordeaux un périple initié pour la
première fois dans le cadre de
l'association pharmaceutoyen avec pour
objectif transmettre aux jeunes les
valeurs de la solidarité et s'il y a
quelque chose qui symbolise bien le
collectif le collectif national c'est
bien la sécurité sociale et je voulais
qu'on leur rende hommage et que les
enfants comprennent ce que c'est qu'un
collectif dans le jeu mais également un
collectif au sein de la nation au sein
de la République près de 600 km plus
tard arrivés au château des lauriers en
Gironde pour le déjeuner résidence de la
famille gradisse au XIXe siècle le
bâtiment héberge le Musée national de
l'assurance maladie depuis 27 ans et
c'est la maîtresse de maison elle-même
qui vient accueillir les visiteurs on
m'a dit vous êtes venus de loin
et ça pour vous instruire
j'en suis enchantée marin poilu ou
messagerie du roi Marie Anthony font
vivre ses personnages sous les yeux des
enfants mais nous on prend un plaisir
énorme parce qu'il y a une valeur qui
est magnifique qui est promu dans cette
visite la solidarité
pour la première fois un chirurgien pour
les mineurs ou encore la mise en place
d'un régime de protection sociale pour
les marins par Aliénor d'Aquitaine une
dizaine de scénettes imaginées depuis
deux ans pour apprendre aux jeunes les
étapes importantes de la création de la
Sécurité sociale en 1945 il faut pouvoir
faire des bons dans le temps et surtout
se remettre dans des ambiances c'est
bien de parler d'une histoire de se
remettre dans un contexte historique
mais on a le matériel on a des pièces de
collection et dans cette pièce en
particulier c'est qu'on a du matériel
d'origine qui a été utilisé à partir des
années 50 entre les années 50 et 70 dans
les centres de paiement des sécurité
sociale
monsieur bonjour comment allez-vous
viens vous êtes contents de travailler
ici deux heures de visite et c'est déjà
l'heure de rentrer les jeunes trappistes
font le point sur leur connaissance la
sécurité sociale c'est les personnes qui
remboursent les quand par exemple on va
chez le médecin les trucs et bah si on
doit payer 23 € et eux ils rembourse par
exemple 15 euros c'est le rock qui a dit
qu'ils allaient le mettre en place au
début c'était il devait guérissait que
les que les mineurs on va dès qu'on a
des problèmes au moins il y a des gens
qui peuvent nous nous sauver
durant le voyage pour résumer simplement
le principe alors une
pour tous pour tous
le collectif c'est effectivement ne pas
jouer seul compter sur son voisin et
faire en sorte que son voisin soit un
allié également dans les dans les bah
dans les difficultés de la vie et en
fait spontanément ils m'ont dit quand
est-ce qu'on repart quand est-ce qu'on
fait quelque chose c'est avec des
souvenirs plein la tête que les enfants
retrouvent leurs parents un peu à
contrecoeur de voir leur périple se
terminer face au succès de cette
première initiative le club de l'Étoile
Sportive de Trappes prévoit déjà
d'autres destinations
alors ça vous rappelle des souvenirs
encore jeune et
c'était le premier le premier de
pharmacie druien pour voilà pour pour
éduquer les enfants vers le
contribuer en tous les cas contribuer à
faire passer des messages sur la
citoyenneté essentiellement le message
cette année-là c'était l'idée que dans
le sport en général ou dans le foot en
particulier parce que ce sont des
footballeurs c'est on fait passer la
balle on donne la balle on reçoit la
balle et la sécu c'est le même principe
ça donne des cotisations et on reçoit
des soins et donc le passage le passage
de témoin se fait comme ça et le message
simple sont là en tout cas merci pour ce
soir deux invités mais tout de suite
d'abord le rappel des infos du jour
une plante d'anticorps 78 visant Sidi
Elmer l'association anticorruption
reproche à l'ancien maire par intérim de
Mantes-la-Jolie un conflit d'intérêt
dans le prolongement d'une convention
d'occupation d'un local municipal à
titre gratuit d'une association lifep
alors que l'échéance n'était pas encore
arrivé et que Sidi elle est mort et le
directeur général de cette association
un second document concerne le bail
professionnel au bénéfice d'une
entreprise dirigée par son frère les
plaintes n'ont pour le moment pas donné
lieu à l'ouverture d'une procédure
judiciaire un coup de projecteur sur
leur carrière à l'occasion de la Journée
internationale des droits des femmes
plusieurs personnalités masculines du
monde de la technologie donne le temps
d'une journée de leur compte à une femme
certains Yvelines noient participent la
raison les femmes sont cinq fois moins
nombreuses dans ce secteur et moins
visible sur la plateforme que leurs
homologues masculins c'est une maladie
qui touche une femme sur dix
l'endométriose elle est devenue sujet
d'une stratégie nationale en janvier
2022 avec la création par l'Agence
régionale de la série de France de
quatre filières dans les Yvelines à les
pilotées par les centres hospitaliers de
Versailles et de Poissy Saint-Germain la
filière se nomme voyelle et a été
officiellement lancée hier mardi 7 mars
et à voyelles couvre le 78 et le 95
ouest et donc a pour mission de
permettre à toutes les femmes qui
présentent de l'endométriose d'avoir un
diagnostic précoce et une prise en
charge adaptée graduée en fonction de sa
situation
à partir du médecin généraliste de la
sage-femme libérale du gynécologue de
ville mais aussi d'autres professionnels
qui vont pouvoir et les aider les
soulager que peuvent être déclinés des
ostéopathes etc la consultation
gynécologique peut permettre d'évoquer
le diagnostic c'est ce qui a été
notifié par la Haute Autorité de Santé
en 2017 dans les recommandations qui
fallait avoir un inter atoire à ces
standardisés et aussi dans la mesure du
possible un examen gynécologique un
examen pelvien qui est qui permet de
détecter des signes la mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites
continuent ce mercredi 8 mars notamment
les transports étaient à nouveau
perturbés une troisième journée de grève
d'affilée ce profil jeudi 9 mars et
l'intersydical annonçait deux nouvelles
journées le samedi 11 mars et le 14 ou
le 15 mars
[Musique]
alors on va accueillir
la Fédération justement souhaite
filmer de plus en plus excusez-moi
donc
on va dire ce rôle là c'est vrai que la
plupart du temps c'est des messieurs et
là on commence justement à les femmes
commencent à être là les femmes
commencent à franchir un petit peu cette
barrière de féminin évidemment bien sûr
des entraîneurs aussi il y a des femmes
entraîneurs
[Rires]
et un peu dans la fédération mais je
vais pas vous comme vous êtes parti de
la Fédération je vais pas vous demander
il faut qu'on donne de l'autorité
beaucoup d'autorités faut quand même une
certaine
autorité un certain mental et parfois
que vous étiez une femme
où est-ce que le nom finalement ça se
passe bien
avant oui c'est vrai que
c'était assez
on peut pas dire table on va pas dire
tabou mais
c'était surprenant
là là maintenant c'est vrai que voilà le
fait de voir une femme
je pense que voilà ça ça apporte une
certaine douceur quand même
sur le contexte
un peu les rapports parce que parfois il
y a quand même des tensions fortes je
suppose exactement
ça m'est déjà arrivé mais c'est vrai que
quand ça nous arrive
on essaie justement de faire en sorte et
je pense que une femme justement apporte
ce petit truc ce petit côté là apporte
cette apaisement une certaine voilà
c'est sérénité on va dire que sans Fatma
j'aimerais qu'elle nous rappelle un peu
son parcours quand même il y a un
parcours donc après après la
présentation donc
quand même investissement modestement
elle le dit pas mais autant tout le
monde sait ce qu'un arbitre l'arbitre
c'est le patron sur le terrain elle est
la patronne en dehors c'est quand même
une patronne et elle a autorité donc à
la d'une certaine manière elle le fait à
sa façon mais son parcours vous verrez
intéressant
justement alors vous avez un métier
qui est dans les dans quoi les sources
humaines c'est ça et puis en dehors de
ça voilà vous vous occupez de d'un club
de foot alors je suis secrétaire
effectivement dans un club de foot tout
à fait oui club de foot de Guyancourt
d'accord
donc je gère toute la partie ce
critérial administratif
ma fille l'année dernière qui jouait
dans les dans les féminines et du coup
j'ai connu le club de cette manière et
on m'a proposé le poste de secrétaire
auquel j'avais voilà que j'ai accepté de
travailler parce que j'avais envie de
voir un peu ce monde au-delà des
ressources humaines de voir un peu le
monde du foot dans sa globalité et à
l'intérieur et puis et puis apporter
aussi quelque chose de de nouveau par
rapport à mon expérience on va dire
professionnelle et puis et puis
tout à fait puisque dans les ressources
ce côté relationnel ce côté un peu
social ce côté aidé les autres
partager apporter donc je m'y retrouve
effectivement oui je me retrouve je me
retrouve un peu
justement dans cette relation que vous
apportez le fait d'être une femme ça
facilite les choses aussi ou comme dit
c'était indifférent ou parfois on dit
tiens bah qu'est-ce qu'une femme fait
ici je l'ai pas entendu encore
mais
non je n'ai pas encore entendu
mais si comme dit Fatna la femme apporte
quand même une certaine douceur
après peut-être que
certains autorité bien sûr oui tout à
fait bien sûr
après je pense que
on a quand on dit les choses il faut à
mon avis il faut
avec le sourire on peut aussi
autoritaire
statistique absolument incroyable je
crois que 30 % des RH qui sont burn out
je ne vais pas partir
les responsabilités comprend sur soi
sont souvent énormes oui puisque on a la
responsabilité des salariés souvent je
suis aussi enfin responsable de paye
voilà et puis aussi la responsabilité un
peu de la société puisque il y a
certains voilà il y a certains dossiers
au niveau de la paye ou autre qui sont
qui sont aussi à notre charge donc on a
une responsabilité plus plus donc oui et
puis on gère de l'humain aussi
je joue pas je suis en plein centre
on vient pas me voir pour me dire tu
sais je n'ai pas joué ce weekend
non pour ça il y a les coachs et puis il
y a d'autres il y a le président le
directeur technique là il y a d'autres
personnes qui sont habiles oui ça va ça
va il y a une peu d'ambiance
comme dans tous les clubs il y en a mais
j'en profite pour remercier tous les
bénévoles des clubs qui font un travail
admirable parce qu'en plus ça prend une
charge supplémentaire parce que en
venant dans le projet de pharmacie
citoyen on lui attribué donc cette
nouvelle charge de s'occuper du projet
pharmaceutoriel donc le club de
Guyancourt comme il y en a dans tous les
clubs des responsables et donc Latifa
fait un boulot formidable justement pour
recruter entre guillemets faire en sorte
que on puisse faire passer nos messages
dans le club par le biais de pharmacie
précédent j'ai une impression comme ça
j'ai l'impression que le monde de
l'entreprise est moins j'en ai
c'est-à-dire qu'on a l'impression que
les femmes disent nous dans l'entreprise
on le sent pas et on avance par contre
dans le monde de l'association de la
société et dans le football amateur en
particulier je pense que la féminisation
est une féminisation par le nombre par
le chiffre et pas forcément par des
postes que vous occupez est-ce que je me
est-ce que je me trompe c'est un peu
vrai effectivement on n'est pas encore
c'est pas encore au goût du jour c'est
pas
on lui enfin moi pour moi je trouve
qu'on devrait plus se laisser la
responsabilité
et la crédibilité justement aux femmes
qui sont sur certains postes dans les
dans voilà dans les clubs de foot là je
parle de foot parce que j'y suis mais
il y a pas
encore quelque chose qui est accepté à
100%. alors justement le parcours de
fortnite
à ce que vous faites aujourd'hui
et part de Trappes exactement ça part de
Trappes
cela fait à peu près ouais un peu plus
de
12-15 ans
12-15 ans à peu près donc j'ai des le
football a toujours été une passion pour
moi
j'en ai joué en loisirs et j'en joue
encore actuellement comme ça justement
merveilleusement
et
j'ai ensuite été
après après avoir joué j'étais
intéressée pour pouvoir coacher donc
j'ai passé mes
diplômes de coach
voilà donc il y a tout un parcours
justement
ce qui n'a pas été simple dans le temps
puisque
encore là maintenant on le voit moins
mais dans le temps
allez on retourne 10 ans en arrière
c'est vrai que pour une femme passer ses
diplômes de coach c'était très compliqué
très compliqué puisque je confirme
exactement
se retrouver la seule femme
autour avec
25 mecs pour passer son diplôme c'est
pas simple aujourd'hui
ça s'améliore on sent justement que
voilà la place de la femme elle a pris
une certaine place mais pas encore
vraiment à 100%. il faut savoir qu'en
France on est vraiment en retard comparé
au Canada aux États-Unis en Suède où le
football féminin est avancé de 10 ans de
10 ans facile on voit que il y a une
aspiration parce que quand on regarde
par exemple des retransmissions de match
on voit que ça tient un public
incroyable exactement donc c'est pas le
c'est pas les jours qui sont en retard
c'est peut-être des institutions c'est
peut-être nos états d'esprits
déjà depuis longtemps c'est vrai que
j'ai
l'opportunité avant que je monte en
Fédération de pouvoir promouvoir le
football féminin au niveau du
département je l'avais commencé sur
trappe je l'avais créé sur sur
explosé ce qui s'est bien passé et
ensuite je l'ai voilà j'ai été au niveau
départemental
et ensuite au niveau Ligue de Paris
régional c'est vrai que on a on a
explosé on a allez on a fait énormément
de travail et tout on a avec la
Fédération de la vue en place plusieurs
plusieurs opérations
mais d'affranchissez la barrière
ou justement on voulait mettre donc en
place là donc la femme la place de la
femme au niveau du football et
je trouve que depuis oui là depuis ces
dernières années ça s'est bien avancé
c'est une question que je pose aux deux
parce que vous connaissez bien le monde
amateur et les clubs de foot amateurs
mais mon sentiment c'est qu'on a fait de
la féminisation avec le en gros pour
avoir plus de licence
plus que de donner de la place
aux femmes
on va dire dans les dans les structures
et les organisations est-ce que vous le
sentez aussi comme ça parce que le
nombre il augmente d'année en année le
nombre donc le nombre de licences donc
on va dire le quasiment le chiffre
d'affaires c'est même très sensible au
niveau des demandes de subvention pour
les uns et pour les autres mais est-ce
qu'on est réellement dans le monde de la
féminisation comme on l'entend dans les
structures
dans le monde d'amateurs je peux pas je
peux pas dire parce que c'est vrai que
maintenant que je suis plus dedans
c'est de je ne sais pas du tout mais
dans le monde professionnel c'est vrai
que
on envoie de plus en plus il y a une
évolution c'est vrai certes mais qui
n'est pas encore justement je trouve
vraiment
juste un mot parce que c'est important
parce que c'est une pharmacie citoyen et
que vous avez un parcours vous
connaissez les clubs de foot c'est
important les clubs de foot la structure
les éducation qu'on donne pour pour
former des futurs citoyens des futurs
citoyens non les valeurs le respect la
discipline le respect l'entraînement le
boulot c'est ça
et vous avez fait et vous en êtes les
amis
Mustapha ce soir qu'est-ce qui se passe
ce soir en fait on prolonge les débats
puisque pharmaceutoyant organise sa
soirée donc journée internationale de
roi des femmes donc on aura on prolonge
le débat et puis ça sera aussi festif
parce que faut pas rester que sur des
discours voilà donc l'histoire et c'est
thaïlencourt Élancourt merci merci
beaucoup à toutes les deux bravo merci
c'est vrai que c'était et merci à tv78
et à vous Patrick
c'est que on a eu voilà des parcours
formidables et des et puis des femmes
qui voilà qui sont bien dans leur peau
et un qui sont pas donner le sentiment
que les cinq qu'on a vu serait les cinq
exceptions elles sont exceptionnelles
mais il y en a d'autres il y a d'autres
femmes qui ont exceptionnel qu'on aurait
pu inviter aussi
représentatif merci merci beaucoup et
puis on parlera des femmes un autre jour
que le 8 mars ça serait ça serait bien
quand même hein qu'on abandonne cette
journée finalement ça veut dire qu'on en
a plus besoin merci beaucoup merci de
nous ça va merci Patrice
[Musique]